quantum mechanics has made the right
predictions so far on every experiment
we've thrown at it that's why many
people are happy to accept quantum
mechanics or at least feel that they
don't have any choice but think about
the situation with Newton's laws before
Einstein's theory of relativity came to
the scene for 200 years Newton's laws
seem to hold perfectly in every
experiment done despite the fact that
they're actually wrong and relativity is
a better description of reality how can
that be because Newton's laws and
relativity give almost the same
predictions on many experiments Newton's
laws are only obviously wrong at high
speeds but people couldn't do those
experiments for a long time so no one
noticed that Newton's laws don't always
work going back to quantum mechanics
it's possible that there's an
alternative theory that makes all the
same predictions as quantum mechanics on
experiments that have been done but
might make different predictions on
certain experiments that haven't yet
been done if an alternative theory
exists maybe you can explain the stuff
without resorting to all the craziness
quantum uses I should probably mention
at this point that if you haven't
watched my last few videos and you've
heard that alternative explanations to
quantum are impossible then you might
want to watch this video explaining
Bell's Theorem and why that isn't the
case anyway today's topic is a theory
called bohmian mechanics or pilot-wave
theory which is an alternative to
quantum mechanics it's a much more
classical theory than quantum to start
off with there's none of this particles
are in more than one state at a time
business a particle always has exactly
one position one speed etc at any given
time this is regardless of whether
they're being measured or not this means
that it's perfectly sensible to talk
about the path the particle took to get
from A to B whereas in quantum a
particle has to take all possible paths
one last thing I'd like to point out
about this theory is that it's fully
deterministic in other words if I know a
particle started out in exactly this
position with this speed then I can use
bohmian mechanics to calculate exactly
where we'll be at any time in the future
just like with Newton's laws there is no
randomness in it but how can that work
we know that there's randomness in the
results of quantum experiments you can
do the same experiment twice and get
different results
how can pilot wave theory explain this
if it's deterministic the answer is that
that randomness is not true randomness
think of a coin it seems like if you
flip a coin then the result is perfectly
random there's no way that you can
figure out where there will be heads or
tails but that's not actually true if
you know which side the coin started on
and all the forces that affected it in
theory you can use Newton's laws to
figure out exactly what you'll get so it
only looks random because we don't know
all the forces I'm going to call this
type of randomness randomness because of
ignorance pilot-wave theory proposes
that the randomness we see in these
experiments is of this type on the other
hand notice how according to quantum
mechanics there is no extra information
that you can gather or calculations that
you can do that will tell you exactly
what the result will be quantum
mechanics has true randomness okay so
how does the theory actually work
remember that Newton's laws tell us that
if you have a particle you can figure
out where it's going to go by knowing
all the forces pushing it some of the
forces that were used to our gravity and
electromagnetism
well biomechanics is just Newton's laws
with one slight adjustment there's an
extra force we'll call this force the
quantum force and this is the really
important bit you figure out what
strength and direction that force pulls
a certain particle using the wave
function you use the exact same wave
function for quantum mechanics for that
particle to calculate the quantum force
I won't explain how that calculation is
done but the point is that the wave
function still plays a central role in
our new theory it's just not the same
kind of role as in quantum mechanics
here the wave function sort of guides
the particle on its path that's why the
theory gets called pilot wave theory
well now we have this extra force that
pulls and pushes a particle so that the
particle will move in some kind of path
how can we use this to explain all of
our quantum experiments let me
illustrate with an impressive example
the double slit experiment hopefully you
remember it we shoot particles through
and they get through if they go through
either one or both of these holes and
then land on a screen where they're
detected the result of course is the
interference pattern
let's try get this result with bohmian
mechanics we assume each particle starts
off somewhere around here and they all
move forward and a few of them make it
to the slits say a particular particle
got to this point inside the slits we
can use the wave function to calculate
its path and it looks pretty crazy
notice if there was no quantum force
there wouldn't be any other forces on it
at all so Newton's laws would tell us
that it would just keep going at the
speed it's going which would look more
like this now what if instead of
starting at that point we started it
very very nearby you see that the
particle now goes on a completely
different path and if you start
somewhere different again it goes
somewhere else but when we originally
shot our particles we weren't 100% sure
exactly where they were so you might
shoot two particles from what you think
is the same spot but according to
bohmian mechanics they could end up in
very different places making the results
look random but the theory says that
this randomness is just randomness from
ignorance ignorance in this case of the
starting positions and it's no more
mysterious than a coin flip now we can
repeat the same calculations for many
particles getting through the slits as
you can see an interference pattern has
emerged how did this work out so
perfectly it all comes back to that
quantum force it's based off the wave
function and designed specifically so
that of the particle is moving under its
influence most will end up where the
wave function is big
basically that force is rigged to make
it give the same answer as quantum
mechanics this leads to some weird
conclusions though imagine we cover up
one slit now let's calculate where a
particle should end
up here's one particles path now we
might naively expect that if we open up
the second slit its path will still look
the same
that's not the case though what changed
the wavefunction the particle itself
doesn't go through both slits but the
wave function does therefore the force
on the particle is now different so in a
way this superposition and interference
business hasn't completely gone away
it's just more hidden now well that's
all I'm going to say about how the
theory works but I'll finish with some
quick thoughts I think pilot-wave theory
is very impressive in the way that it
gives the same answers as quantum but to
me it's most impressive in that it's
shown two completely different
explanations about reality can both
explain the facts will we someday be
able to test which one is true if so how
and if not what does that say about
physics are we really finding out the
truth or are we just telling stories
that work